What went wrong last time
when you got caught
Forgot to be scared. I liked it too much
You ever think about leaving
You're so close
Please stay out of trouble
What if I lost my insurance the pregnancy and birth is gonna be about eight or nine thousand closest place for an abortion?
She said where is it hundreds of miles away?
I'm sorry. It's been a rough time through a lot of people trust me if you saw that house you'd pay us to keep it
Are you gonna get the money Olli?
I'll figure something out
You said if I wanted back in to come see you so you could move say five hundred pills, I'm gonna build
Every day, I'm with mom and she's dying and all I can do is get her some medication
So it hurts less you got something. Yeah, oxy 12 a pillow but ten for you. It's not what I wanted
All right, it just kind of turn into this
I know you're selling again, and I don't appreciate losing customers because you decided to get back in the business
I heard you got a procedure done around here. I'm not trying to get anyone in trouble. Yeah, we you ain't gotta try
It's not too late to back out how do we know we can trust you? What brings you out this way?
How much money you got and step over here? We just really
Didn't exactly go like we planned
Can you do this without getting caught are you sure of course not